of course there been people disputing
what exactly I said weather-wise
[ __ ] or [ __ ] you're gonna talk
that way you should go
this isn't CNN okay we have standards
here language yes
people were saying no he didn't say
[ __ ] he said [ __ ] right well
the point is he says he's these words
that were of course very shocking
a lot of people a very hurtful ignorant
ignorant racist racist okay man you're
on a roll but no you're right and and he
made these comments and a lot of people
of course very upset
I watched you your program that night
and you gave a beautiful talk you've had
a long relationship with the country of
Haiti and the Haitian people and you
gave this beautiful impassioned talk
about it and seeing you speak I thought
that made me want to go to Haiti we've
traveled our show a bunch of times of
course usually in a sense of goodwill
and let's let people laugh at me and
laugh at America a little bit so I that
was the impetus for us going and then I
called you up and said can you help us
out and you had great recommendations
right away yeah I got an email from you
and as soon as I heard you're gone I
just thought it was a great idea I mean
I think one of the things that's so cool
about what you do in the field as
opposed to what you do here wait a
minute
why should there be a distinction and
all of Picasso's work was equally good
yeah but I think courage that is what I
love about your sense of humor is when
you're in feel is that you're you're
having fun with people you're not making
fun of them right and I think and I
think it's going to be great for people
to see Haiti in you know in all its
aspects the good and the bad and and the
the rich and the poor and you know all
the things that frankly the president
knighted States just doesn't understand
or doesn't care about or doesn't see
distinctions though it's almost it's
this idea when you when you go to these
when I've been to these different places
the minute you meet people it changes
everything you actually physically meet
the people all of your notions of the
other drift away now it doesn't mean
that everything's perfect
there is no utopia anywhere on this
planet but you do get a sense of alright
we're all in this together yes I think
and I think yeah and I mean Haiti is so
you know yeah it's the poorest country
in the West in the Western Hemisphere
but it's you know a country can be poor
economically and rich in culture and
rich in the strength of the people and
rich in so many different ways and Haiti
is in that way among the richness of
countries I've ever been to I mean the
Haitian people are incredibly strong
carry themselves with such dignity and
for generations you know have had
governments which have not paid
attention to them which have stolen from
them and yet whatever adversity they
have faced they face it head-on and as I
said you know when when you meet them
they you know Haitians look you in the
eye they slap your hand hard when you
shake it and I think you're gonna have
an unforgettable experience you know
you've had a very special relationship
with Haiti that goes back to your
childhood I mean how far back does it go
at my high school and middle school high
school math teacher was a guy named evil
ell who was from Haiti and he had left
under the Duvalier regime which was the
dictator the last dictator they had and
he was always talking while he was
teaching algebra about Haiti and always
talking about going back and running for
president of Haiti and we were always
like you're our algebra teacher what are
you talking about you're gonna be back
right you can't do that yeah sure enough
Duvalier left the country and evil L
went back and ran for president Haiti
and he was actually assassinated yeah so
so that was sort of my my my
introduction to Haiti and I started
going there as a young report
back in like 94 I say and I go back I've
gone back a lot obviously we were the
first team on the ground after the
earthquake and and I go back on vacation
I go there for weekends I mean it's it's
a it's an amazing place it's an
incredible place you seem to prefer
being in the field almost to being in
the studio and that's an assumption I
have that's true I I mean I actually
love being a studio I like being in
front of an audience but I I there is
something about being in the field where
anything can happen and right do you
enjoy that and it's also I mean it's
it's just magical in the field because
you know it's like the molecules of the
air charge and you you try to cram all
of that into the camera and try to you
know kind of as a reporter you try to
document in the most accurate way
possible and bring people along the
journey and I think that's what's cool
about you know what you do in Cuba or
Mexico and all the places you've been
I've also I liked in Mexico when you
were walking around with a piggy bank
trying to raise money for the wall yeah
you know what's fun about that I had a a
piggy bank and I was walking around and
what was great is the Mexican people who
got the joke immediately I said hey our
president said you guys were paying for
this so you know pay up right and you
know everybody was laughing and his old
woman old women were laughing me going
we're not giving you any money for the
wall and then one guy and that's a clip
that was out there a lot but one guy
said well I've got some money for your
wall right here
[Laughter]
you